so before you go I where we go I want to
send you off with a little piece of
information that will change your life
forever so one of my favorite segments
we call it blow your mind here's
something that's been blowing my mind
recently the the Sun yeah the Sun will
make you go blind
the Sun that we all love it'll make you
go blind the Sun you know I'm dying
around the Sun that thing over our head
every day no matter what if you look at
it you go blind it's crazy and is there
anything you want to look at more up
there shining and shimmering well you're
not allowed any eye contact like it's
Prince
don't look at it you'll fall in love and
here's the weird thing if we didn't have
the Sun there would be no light so it
all be blind but the Sun is the very
thing that makes us not blind and that
will also make you blind do you
understand no Sun blind
too much Sun what